Your body is amazing. Did you know that the bronchial tubes in your lungs are in a row
2400km, which is a quarter of the length of the Great Wall of China?
Or that nails on your dominant hand grow a little faster? Do you hear my voice?
Thank you for the three bones in your ear, which are so small that they fit on one penny.
Without them, you wouldn't hear or be able to balance
Including the smallest bone in your body: stirrup. The longest and strongest bone is the femur
stronger than steel and four times stronger than concrete. You have only 206 bones in adulthood
But as a child you had 300 of them
But they weren't lost, they just grew together. Your lungs are able to breathe in 13 liters of air every minute
a total of 8000-9000 liters per day. Exhale now. Whatever you try, there's always a liter of air left in your lungs
Likewise, your stomach is never completely empty
It always contains 50 ml of hydrochloric acid. Upside down, esophagus
prevents partially digested food in the stomach
fall back into your mouth because it is made up of muscles that contract with a wavy movement known as peristaltic
Which provides unidirectional flow and prevents anything from traveling in the opposite direction. Unless, of course, you vomit
The brain's hypothalamus maintains an optimal body temperature of 37 ° C and works with the skin
sweat glands and vessels to keep that temperature.
When it is hot outside, the blood vessels expand to help release more heat, and sweat glands sweat, so evaporating your skin
When it is cold outside, the blood vessels contract and the blood flow
it is more important for vital organs. Some say the liver has the hardest work in the whole body
They have to perform more than 300 activities every day. When we think about their importance,
No wonder that the largest internal organ in your body is the only one capable of complete regeneration
This jackpot filters everything we eat and drink
including alcohol and drugs, converts glucose into glycogen into a supply
It produces bile that helps with digestion
and even stores iron in the form of ferritin. Your lungs and kidneys work together to maintain and control the optimal blood pH of 7.4
If the pH is higher than 7.8
or less than 6.8 is usually death. When the pH rises, the kidneys release excess
bicarbonates and lungs try to maintain carbon dioxide. When the pH drops, the lungs remove CO2
and the kidneys release more hydrogen ions. Even if you have 2 kidneys and each is not larger than a computer mouse
you can only survive once working at 75%
Inside, there is a network of 1-2 million nephrons, which are tiny filters able to filter
110 to 140 liters of blood per hour. This means that all the blood in your body is filtered through the kidneys 400 times a day
An adult has 5 liters of blood in the body, which is 7% of the total body weight
Of course, your body is full of red blood cells
Right now, 25 trillion wander through a staggering 100,000 kilometer net of blood vessels
Every second, 2 million red blood cells die through spleen filtration, but don't worry, the bone marrow produces 2 million red blood cells every second as a replacement
Your hair is the 2nd fastest growing part of your body, able to grow 15 cm per year although there are different variations
In the population, male hair tends to grow faster than female hair.
Like a newborn, your lungs were filled with fluid
about 10 seconds after birth, you breathed out sharply in response to the new environment and your breathing process that keeps you alive started
Be sure to check out our latest videos by clicking on the screen or by using the links in the description
and subscribe to our channel for additional science videos every Thursday